Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. With 1973, an era died, an era of profligacy unprecedented in human experience, when most Americans embarked on an orgy of consumption following the lean years of the Depression and World War II. This New Year's Day, symbolized by dim lights, chilly rooms and empty gasoline tanks, ushers in a new era of enforced, if only relative, austerity. If the nation and its leadership react wisely,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。伴随着1973年的到来，一个时代宣告终结，那是一个人类经历中空前挥霍的时代，在经历了大萧条和第二次世界大战的清苦岁月之后，大多数美国人沉迷于消费狂欢。新年的第一天，以昏暗的灯光、寒冷的房间和空空如油箱为象征，开启了一个强制的、哪怕只是相对的紧缩的新时代。如果国家及其领导人能够明智地应对，
1974 will also witness the rebirth of an ancient virtue, thrift, and the development of a new national ethic dedicated to the conservation of rapidly vanishing resources, including such elementary essentials as clean air and water, which generations of Americans have heedlessly taken for granted. That, Dominic Sandbrook, was an editorial in the New York Times published on New Year's Day 1974. And I know that you know that because you actually sent it to me. I didn't think I wouldn't have sent it to you if I'd known you would.
1974年也将见证一种古老美德——节俭的复苏，并开创一种全新的国家道德规范，致力于保护迅速消逝的资源，包括纯净的空气和水等基本必需品，而几代美国人曾对此予取予求、习以为常。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），那是《纽约时报》在1974年元旦发表的一篇社论。我知道你知道这一点，因为实际上是你发给我的。我没想到……如果我知道你看了，我就不会发给你了。
That was a magnificent display. And I'm sure American listeners will go, wow, I had no idea that he was American. But you seem to be doing that as Richard Nixon. That was very Nixonian, that accent, I thought. So he's president at the time, right? Yeah, so very appropriate. So that was very moving, actually.
那是一场精彩绝伦的表演。我相信美国听众会发出惊叹，我完全不知道他是美国人。但你刚才似乎是在模仿理查德·尼克森。我觉得那个口音非常有尼克森的特色。所以他当时是总统，对吧？是的，所以非常应景。说实话，这真的很感人。
I thought that was after the Alexander the Great peroration the other week. That was in the same league. Yeah, well, we're hitting homers, as they say stateside. Oh, God. So, Dominic, today's topic is the energy crisis of 1973. Very exciting topic. Yom Kippur War, seven days a week in Britain. Seven days a week, three day a week.
我觉得那跟上周亚历山大大帝的慷慨陈词有得一拼。那是同一个级别的。好吧，正如他们在美国所说，我们正击出全垒打。哦，天哪。所以，多米尼克，今天的话题是1973年的石油危机。非常令人兴奋的话题。赎罪日战争，英国每周七天。每周七天，每周三天。
Three day a week, sorry, yes. I mean, we always have a seven day a week. That's true. Three day a week. But obviously, there's a kind of a context in the headlines of the moment that gives a particular saliency so there was a kind of there was a panic about um everyone in britain filling up their um petrol tanks uh then there's anxiety about whether the gas will run out over this winter yeah um there's a cop is going on at the moment as we're recording this it will
每周三天，抱歉，是的。我的意思是，我们总是每周七天。那是真的。每周三天。但显然，当时的头条新闻中有一种背景，赋予了它特殊的紧迫感，因此当时有一种恐慌，关于英国每个人都在排队加满油箱，然后人们开始担心这个冬天天然气会不会用完，是的，嗯，我们录制节目时正在举行联合国气候变化大会，等这期节目播出时它应该
have finished by the time this goes out, but huge anxieties about energy conservation there. And then, of course, also, there's been the lockdowns with COVID, which, again, there are kind of certain parallels with the mood of crisis that the old crash of 1973 introduced. So I think it's a fascinating topic, but it's also fascinating not just as a kind of mirror held up to our present concerns, but in its own right, is it? It is. It feels like, looking back now, it's the year before I was born, but you were, of course, alive. But it feels like a massive, it feels like a genuine watershed, doesn't it, in modern
已经结束了，但人们对那里的能源节约有巨大的担忧。然后，当然，还有新冠疫情期间的封锁，这再次与1973年老危机带来的危机情绪有某种相似之处。所以我认为这是一个迷人的话题，但它不仅仅是作为一面映照我们当今关切的镜子而引人入胜，它本身就极具魅力，对吧？确实如此。现在回想起来，这似乎是我出生前的一年，但你当时当然已经经历了。但它感觉像是一个巨大的、真正分水岭般的时刻，不是吗，在现代
history? I think, you know one two three hundred years in the future it's conceivable that people will point to the oil crisis of 1973 and say that's a real turning point in the relationship between the west and the rest and in globalization and in the decline of american power and all these kinds of things i think also more broadly it it kind of pinpoints in a way that i hadn't really thought before really profound trends and changes in geopolitics in in the 20th century yeah the rise of the middle east and it's the first time the middle but also the decline of europe yes absolutely absolutely europe is really on the receiving end for the first time in centuries so i think we should we'll come to that
历史中？我认为，你知道在未来一二百年里，人们完全有可能指出1973年的石油危机，并说那是西方与世界其他地区关系、全球化以及美国实力衰落等种种转折点。我也认为，更广泛地说，它以一种我以前没有真正想到的方式，精确定位了20世纪地缘政治中非常深刻的趋势和变化，中东的崛起，这也是中东第一次……还有欧洲的衰落，是的，绝对是绝对的，欧洲几个世纪以来第一次真正首当其冲，所以我想我们应该，我们会在
in in in due course. But to begin with, I mean, again, this is kind of very much a period that you're familiar with, you've written about it both in the American and the British context. But it is conventionally thought that the trigger for this doesn't happen in either Britain or America, but happens in the Middle East with the Yom Kippur War. Yeah. and I think there's, well, we'll sort of pull the camera back and go into the complexities behind it in a little bit. But you're right that there is a sort of sense of a trigger being on a particular day, and that's the 6th of October, 1973.
适当的时候谈到这一点。但首先，我的意思还是，这在很大程度上是一个你非常熟悉的时期，你已经在国内和国际的背景下写过关于它的文章。但传统上人们认为，引发这一切的导火索并不是发生在英国或美国，而是发生在发生赎罪日战争的中东。是的，我认为，好吧，我们稍后会把镜头拉远，深入探讨其背后的复杂性。但你是对的，有一种导火索发生在特定日期的感觉，那就是1973年10月6日。
So as you say, it's the Day of Atonement in Israel. It is one of the holiest days, if not the holiest day in the Jewish calendar. So everyone is going to synagogues and meeting up. Everything has shut down. Yeah. Yeah, everything has shut down. And Israel's regional enemies, so countries like Egypt and Syria that were defeated in 1967, sees this as the opportunity for revenge.
正如你所说，这是以色列的赎罪日。它是犹太历中最神圣的日子之一，如果不是最神圣的话。所以每个人都要去犹太教堂聚会。一切都关门了。对。是的，一切都关门了。以色列的地区敌人，比如在1967年被击败的埃及和叙利亚等国，认为这是一个复仇的好机会。
Because Israel in 67 has seized Suez Peninsula, West Bank, and the Golan Heights. The Golan Heights, exactly. So it's unfinished business. And for the Egyptians, so that's President Sadat. And for the Syrians, that's President Assad, Assad Sr. Yeah, the dad of the current incumbent. Exactly.
因为以色列在67年占领了西奈半岛、约旦河西岸和戈兰高地。戈兰高地，没错。所以这是一笔尚未了结的旧账。对于埃及人来说，那是萨达特总统；对于叙利亚人来说，那是阿萨德总统，老阿萨德。是的，现任总统的父亲。没错。
They see this as the opportunity to strike back. Now, they don't necessarily think they're going to win a crushing victory. They don't think that by any means. But they think that they can change the realities on the ground and the minds of kind of Western policymakers by showing that they're not prepared to be pushed around, that they're still there, and that they can get a better deal at the end of it, I think.
他们认为这是反击的机会。现在，他们不一定认为自己能取得压倒性的胜利。他们绝不这样认为。但他们认为，通过表明自己不甘受欺负、他们依然存在，并且最终能够达成更好的协议，他们可以改变地面的现实和西方决策者的想法，我想。
So they strike, I think, after lunch at about two o'clock. And there had been warnings, but there had been sort of rumours rather, but they'd all been ignored. They strike with Pearl Harbour-esque element of surprise. So Israel is shut down for prayer and they strike and they make astonishing immediate gains, gains which the Israelis will subsequently push back a bit. But it's this sort of devastating moment. And as luck would have it, on the same day, the 6th of October, the oil ministers of the OPEC cartel, of the OPEC oil producing nations, are meeting in Vienna to talk about their latest deal with the big oil companies. And it's the confluence of those two things that is going to change the world. So OPEC is, when is it founded? 19 something. I've got it here somewhere and I can't remember it. 1960. There you go.
所以他们在午饭后大约两点左右发动了袭击。此前曾有过警告，但更像是谣言，结果都被忽视了。他们的袭击带有珍珠港式的出其不意。以色列正放假祈祷，结果他们发动了袭击，并取得了惊人的直接战果，这些战果后来被以色列人稍微打了回去。但这是一个毁灭性的时刻。命运弄人，就在同一天，即10月6日，欧佩克卡特尔（OPEC）即欧佩克产油国组织的石油部长们正在维也纳开会，讨论他们与各大石油公司的最新协议。正是这两件事的交汇将改变世界。那么欧佩克是何时成立的？19某某年。我这里某处有记录，但我记不起来了。1960年。给你找到了。
1960. So there's Venezuela, but the other ones are mostly Muslim. So Saudi Arabia, Kuwait, Iraq, Iran. Exactly. And they all obviously feel strongly about the Palestinian issue. They're hostile to Israel. Yes. And what is fascinating about this is that they had been talk of an oil weapon before. So we had lots of questions saying, does this come out of a kind of clear blue sky? And it doesn't, because there had been rumours of it for years, actually. They've been talk of using the oil weapon in 1967, but it didn't come to anything. But things have changed by 1973. So if you pull
1960年。成员中有委内瑞拉，但其他国家大多是穆斯林国家。比如沙特阿拉伯、科威特、伊拉克、伊朗。没错。他们显然都对巴勒斯坦问题有着强烈的感情。他们对以色列充满敌意。是的。而这其中最迷人的是，此前曾有过使用石油武器的讨论。所以我们收到了很多问题，问这是否是晴天霹雳？其实并不是，因为多年来实际上一直有这方面的传言。早在1967年就有人讨论过使用石油武器，但无疾而终。但到了1973年，情况已经变了。所以如果你往后
right back, what's the context of this? The context is that the Western world, particularly America, but also Western Europe, is using more oil and importing more oil than ever before. So since the late 1940s, worldwide consumption of oil has basically doubled so the energy oil's place in the sort of energy ecosystem has has doubled but in america it's trebled so americans have gone from um consuming 5 million barrels of oil a day to consuming 16 million in the 1940s to so in 30 years they've gone from 5 million barrels of oil a day to 16 million and they've also started importing them so previously america had been an oil producer itself but it's reached saturation you know they've so you know in texas for example they
退一步，这一切的背景是什么？背景是西方世界，尤其是美国，还有西欧，对石油的消耗和进口都达到了前所未有的程度。因此，自20世纪40年代末以来，全球石油消费量基本上翻了一番，因此石油在能源生态系统中的地位翻了一番，但在美国，消费量增加了两倍，因此美国人从40年代每天消耗500万桶石油，增加到消耗1600万桶，所以在30年里，他们从每天消耗500万桶石油增加到1600万桶，而且他们也开始进口石油。在此之前，美国本身是一个石油生产国，但它已经达到了饱和，你知道的，所以在德克萨斯州，他们
are now extracting all they can um so they're beginning to import and america now feels more vulnerable and the western world feels more vulnerable. So we had one question from Duncan Hibbard. Why hadn't the oil-producing countries used their oil power before? So there are two dimensions to it. One is that people are using more oil. And then, of course, the oil countries are no longer under the boot of colonial powers. Right. And so, I mean, this is the kind of when you really pull the camera back.
现在正在竭尽所能地开采，所以他们开始进口，美国现在感到更加脆弱，西方世界也感到更加脆弱。所以我们收到了邓肯·希巴德（Duncan Hibbard）的一个问题。为什么产油国以前没有动用他们的石油权力？所以这有两个层面。一方面是人们消耗更多的石油。然后，当然，产油国不再处于殖民列强的铁蹄之下。对。所以，我的意思是，这就是当你真正把镜头拉远时的情况。
Actually, I mean, it takes us all the way back to our episode on the Industrial Revolution. And one of the key reasons perhaps why it happens in Britain is that we have coal. But the 20th century sees coal replaced by oil as the kind of a key lubricant of industrialization. And obviously, if you have oil, that then puts you in a tremendous position. If you don't, then it's more problematic. America does have loads of oil. And so it's unsurprising that its economy massively takes off in the 20th century. The colonial empires have oil by virtue of ruling empires. So the positions say of Britain and France, it's hugely important to them that they keep their supplies of oil. Right, exactly. And there's a sense, you know, also if you look at, I suppose, Germany in the Second World War, Germany's lack of oil becomes a kind of crucial factor in its ultimate defeat.
实际上，我的意思是，这把我们一路带回了关于工业革命的那集节目。英国之所以发生这种情况的一个关键原因，或许是我们拥有煤炭。但20世纪见证了煤炭被石油取代，成为工业化的关键润滑剂。显然，如果你有石油，这就会让你处于一个极其有利的地位。如果没有，那就更成问题了。美国确实拥有大量的石油，因此它的经济在20世纪蓬勃发展也就不足为奇了。殖民帝国凭借统治帝国而拥有石油。因此，对英国和法国等国的立场而言，保持石油供应对他们来说至关重要。没错，确实如此。而且有一种感觉，你知道的，如果你看看德国在二战中的情况，德国缺乏石油成为其最终失败的关键因素。
Why do they go to the Caucasus? Why do they go to Stalingrad? They're after the oil. Yeah. So you can kind of see the fight to secure oil supplies as being kind of one of the absolutely key motives of geopolitics in the transition. You absolutely can. And there's a brilliant book about this for listeners. I know listeners always rightly lecture us for our failure to put reading lists online. But if there's one book you should read about this, if you're interested, it's called The Prize by an American writer called Daniel Yergin. It's an absolutely brilliant book. It almost reads like a thriller. It's so interesting about the oil companies and about the geopolitical kind of the quest for oil, basically. And he says this was a prize beyond compare in human history. And um and actually tom you're talking about the
他们为什么去高加索？为什么去斯大林格勒？他们是冲着石油去的。是的。所以你可以看出，争夺石油供应的争端可以说是转型期地缘政治绝对核心的动机之一。你完全可以这么说。对于听众来说，有一本关于这方面的极好书籍。我知道听众总是理所当然地指责我们没有把书单放到网上，但如果你对这个感兴趣，如果有哪本书是你必须读的，那就是美国作家丹尼尔·尤金（Daniel Yergin）写的《巨奖》（The Prize）。这是一本绝对精彩的书。读起来几乎就像惊悚片一样。它关于石油公司和地缘政治基本对石油的追寻，是如此有趣。他说，这是人类历史上无与伦比的巨奖。而且，汤姆，你刚才谈到那个
colonial stuff there are the big oil producing opec nations particularly saudi arabia iran iraq i mean they're the big players all of which are under british yes but then if you look at the so-called seven sisters so they're the oil companies and they are i have it written down to remind myself they're the ang Anglo-Iranian Oil Company. That's BP. There is Royal Dutch Shell, which is Shell, which is a majority Dutch but minority British. So the Dutch, obviously, because they had oil in Indonesia.
殖民地的事情，欧佩克的大型产油国，特别是沙特阿拉伯、伊朗、伊拉克，我的意思是，它们是主要玩家，所有这些都在英国的统治之下，是的。但如果你看看所谓的“七姐妹”，也就是那些石油公司，我有写下来提醒自己，它们是英伊石油公司（Anglo-Iranian Oil Company）。也就是BP（英国石油）。还有荷兰皇家壳牌（Royal Dutch Shell），也就是壳牌，由多数荷兰资本和少数英国资本组成。所以荷兰人，显然是因为他们在印度尼西亚拥有石油。
And then you have the five American, three standard oil companies, which were broken up in the progressive era from one to sort of break up the monopoly. And then you have, which were broken up, but in the progressive era, from Warn to sort of break up the monopoly. And then you have Gulf Oil and Texaco, and the name suggests they're basically Texas. And you've got Elf, the French company, Elf? French is Elf, yeah. That's kind of a compound of different
然后你有五家美国公司，三家标准石油公司，它们在进步时代被拆分，以打破垄断。然后你有……它们被拆分了，但在进步时代，为了打破垄断，从沃恩……然后你有海湾石油（Gulf Oil）和德士古（Texaco），从名字就可以看出它们基本上属于德克萨斯州。还有埃尔夫（Elf），那家法国公司，埃尔夫？法国的是埃尔夫，是的。那是不同
various companies. It is. Elf is the kind of mini-tale of the oil. It's like that French vaccine that they tried to produce for COVID, which was a complete shambles and a disaster. You know, that's how I regard Elf. Anyway, that's one for our French listeners. Do we have any?
各个公司的复合体。是的。埃尔夫就像是石油界的小尾巴。就像法国人试图为新冠疫情生产的那种疫苗，完全是一团糟和灾难。你知道的，这就是我对埃尔夫的看法。不管怎样，这是给我们法国听众准备的。我们有法国听众吗？
No, I don't think we've ever had a French listener. And I think if we did, we'd drive them away within minutes. Well, Agnes, we had Agnes by you. Yeah, we did. Apart from her. She's very forgiving. Yes, okay.
不，我想我们从来没有过法国听众。我想如果我们有的话，我们几分钟内就会把他们吓跑。好吧，艾格尼丝，我们有艾格尼丝支持你。是的，我们有。除了她。她非常宽容。是的，好吧。
So essentially the retreat of European colonialism from the Middle East, which is kind of turbocharged by America, really. I mean, so Suez plays a key role in that, actually is terrible for America in the long run. It is. And actually the Americans are really concerned throughout the 60s. They don't want... See, there's a common misconception
所以本质上，欧洲殖民主义从中东的撤退，实际上是由美国真正推波助澜的。我的意思是，苏伊士运河事件在其中发挥了关键作用，从长远来看对美国来说实际上是糟糕透顶的。确实如此。而且实际上整个60年代美国人都非常焦虑。他们不想要……看，有一个普遍的误解
that the Americans wanted to push Britain out of the Middle East. And that's not really true. It's more complicated than that. The Americans were not fans of Britain's formal empire, but they wanted Britain to remain informally as a Cold War ally. Because the United States is basically subsidising Britain
认为美国人想把英国赶出中东。这其实并非事实。情况要复杂得多。美国人并不赞成英国的正式帝国，但他们希望英国以非正式的冷战盟友身份留下来。因为美国基本上在补贴英国，
to keep its kind of colonial possessions in the Gulf, right? Yeah. And throughout the 60s and throughout the 60s, Lyndon Johnson is saying to Harold Wilson, because one of Wilson's things is he wants to withdraw from east of Suez. So he wants to pull back from Aden, for example. And the Americans are very jittery about
让它维持在海湾地区的殖民统治，对吧？是的。在整个60年代，林登·约翰逊一直在对哈罗德·威尔逊说，因为威尔逊的主张之一是他想从苏伊士以东撤军。所以他想从亚丁撤出，例如。而美国人对此感到非常紧张，
this, because they say that will basically leave a vacuum that the Soviet Union and Arab nationalists will walk into. I mean, people aren't worried particularly about Islamism at this stage. They're more worried about kind of Nasserism, about nationalist Arab regimes that get into bed with the communist world. With the Russians, yeah.
因为他们说这基本上会留下一个权力真空，苏联和阿拉伯民族主义者会趁虚而入。我的意思是，现阶段人们并不特别担心伊斯兰主义。他们更担心纳赛尔主义，担心那些与共产主义世界勾结的阿拉伯民族主义政权。与俄国人勾结，是的。
Yeah, and that is the big fear because they know about the importance. I mean, it's a myth that people were unaware of the oil weapon. They knew about it. There had been reports from the late 60s onwards and warnings. And when you get to about 1971, the OPEC nations are already asking for more money from the oil companies. Okay, but that's still, we've still got this question from Duncan Hibbard. Why hadn't the oil producing countries used their oil power before?
是的，那是最大的恐惧，因为他们知道其重要性。我的意思是，人们不知道石油武器的说法是一个神话。他们是知道的。从60年代末开始就有相关的报告和警告。到了1971年左右，欧佩克国家就已经开始向石油公司索要更多的钱了。好吧，但我们仍然有邓肯·希巴德的那个问题。为什么产油国以前不使用他们的石油权力？
I mean, they must know that this is an absolute jugular that they can squeeze. So why have they not tried it before? So there's pressure from some of the smaller countries like Algeria and Libya. They say, you have this power, because this is an age of kind of pan-Arabism, for example, and intense anti-Zionism. So they're saying in the late 1960s, why don't you use it?
我的意思是，他们肯定知道这是他们可以扼杀对方命脉的绝招。那为什么他们以前不试一下呢？所以来自阿尔及利亚和利比亚等一些较小国家的压力很大。他们说，你们拥有这种权力，因为这是一个泛阿拉伯主义的时代，例如，还有强烈的反犹太复国主义。所以他们在20世纪60年代末就在说，你们为什么不用它呢？
And the key person is King Faisal of Saudi Arabia. So he's a moderniser. He's been trying to modernise the kingdom. He's doing things like outlawing slavery in the 1960s. And he's a big American and British. He's a Wook King. He's a Wook King. I hadn't thought of that.
而关键人物是沙特阿拉伯国王费萨尔。所以他是一个现代主义者。他一直在试图让王国实现现代化。他在20世纪60年代做了一些事情，比如取缔奴隶制。他是一个坚定的美国和英国支持者。他是一个“觉醒的国王”。他是一个“觉醒的国王”。我没想到这一点。
But he's also very pro-American, right? He's very pro-American, very pro-American, very pro-British. He resists that and keeps resisting it. But the pressure on him is building. And I think you can see months before the Yom Kippur War that he's going to turn. In May 1973, he tells the meeting of American oil executives, you have to persuade your administration to change its policy because I can't hold out much longer. But also he believes it, doesn't he?
但他也非常亲美，对吧？他非常亲美，非常亲英。他对此进行抵抗并继续抵抗。但他面临的压力正在积聚。我想你可以在赎罪日战争爆发前几个月看出他要转变态度了。1973年5月，他在对美国石油高管会议的讲话中表示，你们必须说服你们的政府改变政策，因为我快坚持不下去了。而且他也深信这一点，不是吗？
I mean, he's genuinely very, very hostile to Israel. He'd like to see the Zionist entity swept into the sea. Yes, he would. But he's by the standards of some of the people around him. He's a relative moderate. So in September 1973, so almost literally a month, I think a month and two days before the Yom Kippur War breaks out, he goes on American television, on NBC, and he says, you can't have both your support for Zionism, as he calls it, and all the oil at such cheap rates. You have to choose one or the other. And that interview creates quite a stir in the United States. So it's one of those stories, so common actually, one of those stories
我的意思是，他真心实意地对以色列非常非常敌视。他很想看到犹太复国主义实体被扫进大海。是的，他确实想。但以他身边某些人的标准来看，他是一个相对温和派。所以在1973年9月，也就是赎罪日战争爆发前几乎整整一个月，我想是一个月零两天前，他上了美国电视节目，在全国广播公司（NBC）上说，你们不能既支持犹太复国主义——他这么称呼的——又享受如此便宜的石油价格。你们必须二者选其一。那次采访在美国引起了不小的轰动。所以这是一个很常见的故事，实际上非常普遍，
where there's all this in the ether beforehand and then once it happens everybody forgets. Of course that was going to happen. Yeah. It's sort of looming there. So that's the that's the context for the for the Yom Kippur war let's go back to um the onset of the war it breaks out um Israel is buckling beneath the attack um America starts to seriously worry that that
就是在此之前所有这些情绪都在空气中弥漫，一旦事情发生了，每个人都忘记了。这本来就是必然要发生的。是的。它就那样隐约出现。所以这就是赎罪日战争的背景，让我们回到战争的爆发，战争爆发了，以色列在攻击下摇摇欲坠，美国开始严重担心以色列可能会被彻底击败，是的，好吧，
Israel might be completely defeated yeah well I Well, I mean, yes, I suppose there's definitely concerns about it. But with reference to what you were describing about the Saudi king going on American television and saying you've got to choose between Israel and oil. In due course, is it not the case that Nixon, who is president at the time, friend of the show, of course. A great friend of the show. Great friend of the show, of course. A great friend of the show. Great friend of the show. That he gets a kind of message from Golda Meir, the Israeli prime minister, saying, you know, you've got to airlift stuff in to help us because otherwise we're going under. At the same time as he's also getting a message from the heads of all the American oil companies
我的意思是，是的，我想确实有这方面的担忧。但关于你刚才描述的沙特国王上美国电视说你必须在以色列和石油之间做出选择这件事，适逢其会的是，当时的总统尼克森——当然是节目的老朋友。节目的好朋友。当然是节目的好朋友。他收到了以色列女首相果尔达·梅厄（Golda Meir）发来的信息，大意是：你知道的，你们必须空运物资来帮我们，否则我们就完蛋了。与此同时，他也收到了所有美国石油公司巨头的信件，
saying, look, don't do anything to help Israel or we're going to have all the oil cut off. That's exactly what happens. I mean, he basically has the two letters in the same morning, I think. The letter from Golda Meir saying, send us aid. We need tanks, we need artillery, we need ammunition. And the letter from the heads of Exxon and Standard Oil and so on that says, whatever you do, don't give the Israelis any aid. And he has to decide.
说：听着，千万别做什么帮以色列的事，否则我们的石油全都会被断供。事情正是这样的。我的意思是，我想他基本上是在同一个早晨收到了这两封信。果尔达·梅厄的信说，给我们运送援助。我们需要坦克、大火炮、弹药。埃克森美孚和标准石油等公司高管的信则说，无论如何都不要给以色列任何援助。他必须做出决定。
And a really important factor here, and if we hadn't already done our epic watergate marathon which i commend to the listeners if they haven't listened to it already um then we could go into this in a big way nixon's in the absolute throes of watergate he's about to get rid of his special prosecutor archibald cox so he is a wreck of a man i mean he's an absolute wreck and so it's kissinger it's kissinger who's running this it's really Kissinger who's running this. It's really Kissinger who's running this. And Kissinger, of course, is the great kind of geopolitical, you know. Chess player.
这里有一个非常重要的因素，如果我们之前没有做过我们的水门事件马拉松史诗节目（如果听众还没听过的话，我向大家推荐），那么我们就可以深入探讨这一点。尼克森正处于水门事件的绝对水深火热之中，他正准备解雇他的特别检察官阿奇博尔德·考克斯（Archibald Cox），所以他整个人精神崩溃了。我的意思是，他绝对是个废人。所以是基辛格，是基辛格在掌控这一切。确实是基辛格在掌控这一切。而基辛格，当然是那种伟大的地缘政治，你知道的……国际象棋大师。
Chess player, exactly, by his own estimation, if nobody else is. So Kissinger says, you know, Israel is our... But it is high stakes, isn't it? Because it's a proxy war between America and the Soviet Union. It is, absolutely. They put the American forces eventually on nuclear alert because they're worried about the Soviet Union intervening. So Kissinger says, we have to stand by Israel. Israel is our key ally in the Middle East.
国际象棋大师，没错，据他自己估计，如果别人不算的话。所以基辛格说，你知道，以色列是我们的……但这 stakes 很高，对吧？因为这是美国和苏联之间的代理人战争。确实如此，绝对是的。他们最终让美军进入了核戒备状态，因为他们担心苏联会进行干预。所以基辛格说，我们必须支持以色列。以色列我们在中东的关键盟友。
We just have to do this. So they have what's called Operation Nickel Grass. They're going to send thousands, hundreds of thousands of tons of tanks and guns and all this stuff. Now, here's a really fascinating thing. The Europeans don't want to know. With the exception of one country, which is – well, two countries, actually, Tom, in that case. Two countries. Portugal, a Salazarist dictatorship, very, very right-wing, very anti-communist. They're well up for it. And, as you say, the Netherlands.
我们必须这么做。所以他们进行了所谓的“镍草行动”（Operation Nickel Grass）。他们要运送数千、数十万吨的坦克、枪支和所有这些东西。现在，这里有一个非常迷人的事情。欧洲人根本不想搭理。除了一个国家——好吧，汤姆，其实是两个国家。两个国家。葡萄牙，一个萨拉查式的独裁政权，非常非常右翼，极度反共。他们非常乐意。还有，正如你所说的，荷兰。
Now, I know you're a big fan of the Netherlands. A big fan of the Netherlands. Hence the name. so um but but yeah britain and france don't and britain i mean britain's because britain is historically a pro-israel country had been in the 60s but under heath which is kind of european unity is what matters to heath yeah he knows that the mood inside the common market which he has just joined in January of 73, is against this. Now, the Netherlands is different. Heath refuses to allow American planes to use the bases in Cyprus. So they use bases in Portugal.
现在，我知道你是荷兰的超级粉丝。荷兰的超级粉丝。难怪名字叫这个。但是，英国和法国却没有，而且英国——我的意思是英国，因为英国历史上是一个亲以色列的国家，在60年代确实如此，但在希思（Heath）领导下，欧洲团结对希思来说才是最重要的。是的，他知道刚刚在73年1月加入的共同市场内部的情绪是反对这一点的。现在，荷兰则不同。希思拒绝允许美国飞机使用塞浦路斯的基地。所以他们使用了葡萄牙的基地。
So without the Portuguese help, it would have been much harder for the Americans. And the Portuguese end up being punished for this. And as for the Dutch, you know the story of the Dutch. The Dutch had had a special relationship with Israel based on arms sales. So the Dutch had been – Oh, I thought you were going to say – Based on what? Well, I don't know, the Holocaust or something.
所以如果没有葡萄牙的帮助，美国人要困难得多。葡萄牙最终因此受到了惩罚。至于荷兰，你们知道荷兰的故事。荷兰与以色列有着基于武器销售的特殊关系。所以荷兰一直是——哦，我还以为你要说——基于什么？嗯，我不知道，大屠杀什么的。
Yeah, no, no, no. It's based on making money from guns. Right, okay. So the Dutch – And Frank or – See, I know you worship the dutch you have this very romantic vision of them as sort of they're hard-headed capitalists yeah they were behaving in a very 17th century way hard-headed they were they'd been selling weapons to israel so um so
对，不，不，不。这是基于靠卖枪赚钱。好吧。所以荷兰——弗兰克还是——看，我知道你崇拜荷兰人，你对他们有一种非常浪漫的看法，认为他们是那种精明的资本家，是的，他们当时在以一种非常17世纪的方式行事，精明干练，他们一直在向以色列出售武器，所以
they actually are one of the they're the sort of one country that really of the common market that doesn't want to you know that goes that goes against the general policy and actually wants to support Israel. So the Americans have been, they know that they have this kind of OPEC gun pointed at their head. Yeah, sort of Damocles. Presumably there is no attempt to disguise the fact that they're airlifting large quantities of tanks. There is an attempt to disguise it, but it's completely futile
他们实际上是共同市场中真正的一个国家，不希望……违背总体政策，实际上想要支持以色列。所以美国人一直都知道，欧佩克的枪正顶在他们的头顶上。是的，达摩克利斯之剑。据推测，他们没有试图掩盖他们正在空运大量坦克的事实？他们试图掩盖，但完全是徒劳的，
because it's obvious that it's massive planes landing and tanks rolling off so so here's my question you said right at the beginning that um as luck would have it the yom kippur war starts on the same day that opec members are meeting yeah is it luck though yeah or is or is this coordinated no it's not coordinated it's not coordinated. It's not coordinated. It's not because it's quite a slow... What we think of as the oil bombshell actually happens over a series of days and indeed weeks. Because the key date then is the 16th of October, right? So that's six days after the outbreak of the war. What's happened?
因为很明显那是巨大的飞机降落，坦克从上面开下来。所以我的问题是，你一开始就说，命运弄人，赎罪日战争和欧佩克成员国开会在同一天开始。是的。但这真的是巧合吗？还是说这是协调好的？不，这不是协调好的。这不是协调好的。这不是因为这是一个相当缓慢的过程……我们所认为的石油重磅炸弹实际上是在几天甚至几周内发生的。因为关键日期是10月16日，对吧？也就是战争爆发六天后。发生了什么？
So the 16th of October, there's a meeting in Kuwait City. Yeah. So they're no longer in Vienna. They've moved. They've moved to Kuwait. What's the state of play on the battlefield at this point? So on the battlefield, the Arab offensive has ground to a halt. The Israelis have pushed them back. It's sort of
所以10月16日，在科威特市有一场会议。是的。所以他们不再在维也纳了。他们转移了。他们搬到了科威特。此时战场上的形势如何？所以战场上，阿拉伯人的进攻已经陷入停滞。以色列人把他们逼退了。情况
getting back to... The Israelis have had a terrible shock, but they are clearly not going to be swept into the sea. They're not going to lose the war. And by this point, does it look like they're clawing everything back and and yes exactly yes yes um so so now it's it's down to opec to try and stop israel from kind of i don't know because because israeli armies are kind of moving in on cairo right and and they're shelling damascus and the israelis have made great progress but i don't think it's so much about winning the war, as it were, as it, don't forget the OPEC, they were already pressing for a better deal.
正在恢复……以色列人受到了可怕的打击，但他们显然不会被扫入大海。他们不会输掉这场战争。而且到这个时候，看起来他们是在收复所有失地吗？是的，绝对是，是的，是的，所以现在这取决于欧佩克，试图阻止以色列……我不知道，因为以色列军队正在向开罗推进，而且他们在炮轰大马士革，以色列人取得了巨大进展，但我不认为这主要是关于赢得战争，而是，别忘了欧佩克，他们已经在争取更好的协议了。
Suddenly, fate has almost delivered into their hands the obvious kind of pretext, if you like, for demanding a better deal. And just the political pressure is such that, you know, if you've got the, they know they have this weapon because the West is guzzling so much oil. Because obviously, one thing we didn't mention, by the way, was cars. They know they have this weapon because the West is guzzling so much oil. Because obviously, one thing we didn't mention, by the way, was cars. I mean, the development of the automobile economy in the 50s, 60s, 70s is such a huge part of this. So if they're not going to use that weapon now, when are they ever going to use it? So it's not so much because of realities on the ground. I just think it's a series of pressures so the 16th of october the the delicates um of opec six gulf states massively massively hike the the price of oil
突然之间，命运几乎将一个显而易见的借口（如果你愿意这么说的话）送到了他们手中，让他们去要求更好的协议。而且政治压力如此之大，你知道，如果他们拥有……他们知道自己拥有这个武器，因为西方消耗了太多的石油。因为显然，我们刚才没提到的一点是汽车。他们知道自己拥有这个武器，因为西方消耗了太多的石油。因为显然，我们刚才没提到的一点是汽车。我的意思是，50、60、70年代汽车经济的发展是这其中巨大的一部分。所以如果他们现在不用这个武器，他们什么时候才能用？所以这与其说是由于地面的现实，不如说是一系列压力造成的。所以10月16日，欧佩克的代表们，六个海湾国家，大规模地、大幅度地抬高了石油价格。
70 70 in a day yeah wow and per barrel i mean incredible um and the saudi oil minister sheikh ahmed zaki yamani we are masters of our own commodity. Yeah, now he's a really interesting, he's the mastermind. He's actually the protagonist in some ways of Daniel Juergen's book, The Prize. He is the guy who is the great strategist of the sort of Saudi oil policy. And he absolutely sees this as a chance. You know, we had some questions saying, Dave Walters asked a question. He says, is it mainly about suppliers
一天之内涨了70%！70%！哦，天哪。每桶的价格，简直难以置信。沙特石油大臣谢赫艾哈迈德·扎基·亚马尼（Sheikh Ahmed Zaki Yamani）说：我们是我们自己商品的 주인（主宰者）。是的，他是一个非常有趣的人，他是幕后主谋。他在丹尼尔·尤金的书《巨奖》中实际上在某种程度上是主角。他是沙特石油政策伟大战略家的代表人物。他绝对把这看作一个机会。你知道，我们收到了一些问题，戴夫·沃尔特斯（Dave Walters）提出了一个问题。他说，这主要是关于供应商为他们的产品寻求更公平的价格吗？我的意思是，你也可以这么看。你可以说他们基本上觉得自己受到了剥削。利润长期流向了“七姐妹”石油公司。谢赫亚马尼和其他人说，这是我们的时刻。
seeking a fairer price for their product? I mean, you can see it that way, actually. You can say that basically they feel they've been exploited. The profits have gone to the Seven Sisters oil companies for too long. And Sheikh Yamani and others saying, this is our moment.
我们要收回我们自己的商品，为它得到一个公平的价格。而这正是他们开始蜂拥而至购买赛马的时刻，完全是的，他们买下了梅菲尔（Mayfair），你知道的，他们基本上立刻就涌入了公园巷（Park Lane）的豪华酒店之类的地方，是的，是的。而在第二天，即10月17日，他们开始以更有针对性的方式使用这个武器，因为那禁令，他们宣布了大规模的减产和禁运，他们说，只有当你是一个友好国家时，你才能得到石油，所以如果你是加拿大，如果你是日本，如果你
We are going to take back our own commodity and get a fair price for it. And this is kind of the point where they all start coming over and buying racehorses and exactly yeah they pay up mayfair and you know they basically immediately pitch up in park lane luxury hotels and stuff yes yes and the next day the 17th that's when they start to use the weapon in a more targeted way because that's when they announce big production cutbacks and embargoes and they say you're only going to get oil if you're a friendly country so if you're canada if you're japan if
是英国，如果你是荷兰，或者如果你是葡萄牙，也就是那些最可靠的以色列盟友，你将从我们这里得不到任何石油。但英国得到了，对吧？嗯，英国……英国算是得到了一点优待，因为他们做的是逐渐减产，所以你会看到越来越大的减产幅度和越来越严的禁令，所以他们基本上不是一下子全部实行的，不是一个铁板一块的东西，对吧？这是一系列措施。但美国才是真正受冲击最严重的焦点，而且神奇的是，正是在这个时刻，尼克森解雇了水门事件特别检察官。我的意思是，他整晚熬夜，汗流浃背，忧心忡忡，
you're the united kingdom if you're the netherlands or if you are portugal i.e those countries that are the most reliable allies of israel um you're not going to get any oil from us but britain does doesn't it well britain britain kind of got a got a pass because what they do is they start to cut back gradually so you get bigger and bigger cutbacks and and the embargoes become tighter and tighter so they basically don't it's not like all one monolithic thing right it's a series of measures but it's the united states is the real folk is the u.s is hit most severely and it and it's a the amazing thing is that it's exactly this moment that nixon is is sacking the watergate prosecutor i mean he's staying up all night sweating and worrying
因为基辛格去了莫斯科谈判，是的，一切都在周围分崩离析。绝对是这样。所以在这个时刻，基辛格……有传言说基辛格和美国的将军们在说，如果尼克森下达命令，不要服从他，因为他已经疯了，世界正在崩溃和毁灭中，我们在不知不觉中就会迎来第三次世界大战。我的意思是，当时有一种绝对的末日灾难感，因为，你知道，如此大规模的减产，所有的这些减产。所以在11月5日，欧佩克国家将减产幅度提高到25%。这有一种巨大的通货膨胀注入世界经济的感觉，
about because kissinger goes to moscow yes negotiate and yeah and everything is falling to pieces all around absolutely so this moment that um kissinger there's this talk that uh kissinger and the generals in america are saying if Nixon gives you an order, don't obey it because he's gone mad and the world is collapsing and ruins and we could have World War III before we know it. I mean, there's this absolute sense of apocalyptic disaster at this moment because, you know, such a big production, all these production cuts. So on 5th of November, the opec countries are going to 25 production cuts it's this sense of a massive injection of inflation into the world economy
而且我也认为，特别是对美国而言，汽油的供应，是的，这只是被视为理所当然的，不是吗？30美分，一加仑30美分。我的意思是，他们基本上是免费送的，这就是为什么所有的汽车都那么耗油，因为你甚至都不用去想它。所以每当你看到60年代和70年代初的电影，你知道的，我不禁想起005——《金刚钻》（Diamonds Are Forever），为了顺应我们的邦德主题，他们驾驶的那些巨大的汽车，都是建立在……是的，都是建立在汽油基本上永远不会花你钱的前提下的。如果突然之间他们不得不排队买汽油，那确实是美国生活方式的终结。是的，我认为这是一个巨大的心理冲击。
but also i thought particularly for america where the availability of gasoline yeah it's just kind of taken for granted isn't it 30 30 cents 30 cents a gallon i mean they're basically giving us away and so that's why all the cars are gas guzzling because you don't even think about it so that whenever you watch a film from the 60s and early 70s you know i don't diamonds are forever to pursue our bond theme the ginormous cars that they drive are predicated yeah are predicated on the fact that gas will basically never cost you anything. So it really is then the end of the American way if suddenly they have to queue up for gas. Yeah, I think it's an absolutely colossal psychological shock.
你可以通过各种方式在美国看到这一点。所以尼克森在终于振作起来后，告诉国会必须这样做，各州必须实施不同的限速。他想要夏令时。他做了一些事情，比如关掉白宫所有的灯，并卸下了白宫圣诞树上的许多灯泡。还有这些非同寻常的故事。
And there are all kinds of ways in which you can see it in America. So Nixon, when he finally drags himself to himself, he tells Congress that there has to be, the states have to impose different speed limits. He wants daylight saving time. He does things like he turns out all the lights in the White House and he takes a lot of the light bulbs off the White House Christmas tree. And there were these extraordinary stories.
所以他任命了一个叫比尔·西蒙（Bill Simon）的人担任他的国家能源沙皇。比尔·西蒙试图制定一个按州分配汽油的系统，结果完全是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。他是不是把自己比作阿尔伯特·施佩尔（Albert Speer）？他确实这么说了。他说他希望自己能成为第三帝国的阿尔伯特·施佩尔，结果事情并没有完全按照那个方向发展。好吧，那是……被判终身监禁。是的。我的意思是，有一个故事说他的妻子不再使用他的信用卡了，因为她感到太尴尬了，
So he appoints a guy called Bill Simon to be his kind of national energy czar. And Bill Simon tries to work out a system of allocating petrol state by state. And it's a complete and utter disaster. Didn't he compare himself to Albert Speer? He does. He says he hopes he's going to be Albert Speer
因此，他任命了一个名叫比尔·西蒙的人担任他的国家能源沙皇。比尔·西蒙试图建立一个按州分配汽油的系统。结果这是一场彻底的灾难。他不是把自己比作阿尔伯特·施佩尔吗？他确实这么做了。他说他希望自己能成为阿尔伯特·施佩尔
in the Third Reich, and it doesn't quite work out that way. Well, that's... Go to prison for life. Yeah. Well, I mean, there's a story that his wife stopped using his credit cards because she was so embarrassed to be,
在第三帝国时期，结果事情并没有完全按照那个方向发展。嗯，那是……被判终身监禁。是的。我的意思是，有这样一个故事：他的妻子停止使用他的信用卡，因为她感到太尴尬了，
you know, people shouted to her in public. Because gas stations run dry all across the US. People are kind of shooting at each other. There's a shootout in Indiana. There's a man who blows himself up in Pennsylvania because he's been storing gasoline in the trunk of his car. I mean, just a real sense of sort of shambles and kind of breakdown. And so this, I mean, this kind of then generates a kind of particular tone of apocalyptic hysteria. Yeah. That we see in films of the kind of the time in science fiction, science fiction in,
你知道的，人们在公众场合冲她喊叫。因为全美各地的加油站都断油了。人们甚至开始互相开枪。印第安纳州发生了一场枪战。宾夕法尼亚州有一个人因为把汽油存放在汽车后备箱里而把自己炸死了。我的意思是，这真是一种混乱和崩溃的感觉。所以这，我的意思是，这种状况随后产生了一种特殊的末日歇斯底里基调。是的。我们在那个时代的电影、科幻小说、科幻电影中，
in lots of kinds of books that project the future. Yeah. And I suppose in the long run, the, the kind of panic about the relationship between the environment and oil consumption that is still very much with us today, although it's obviously kind of evolved and been reconfigured. Nevertheless, that sense that our use of oil isn't just something innocent, that it might be, you know, that perhaps the only way we can save
以及许多预测未来的书籍中都能看到这一点。是的。我想从长远来看，那种对环境与石油消耗之间关系的恐慌，在今天依然伴随着我们，尽管它显然已经有所演进和重构。尽管如此，那种认为我们对石油的使用并非完全无辜的想法，它可能是——你知道的，也许我们自救的唯一方法
ourselves is to row back on it. This is really when it begins. I think absolutely when it begins. I think it's the beginning of two things, Tom, actually. One is, you mentioned earlier that sense of the decline of the American dream, a dream which is based on the idea of ever expanding economic affluence. There's an amazing quote, actually, from an American oil executive, which you would enjoy. He says, it was the ebbing of American power by the Romans retreating from Hadrian's wall. I do like that.
就是倒退回去。这确实是从这个时候开始的。我认为绝对是从这个时候开始的。汤姆，我认为这是两件事的开始。第一，你刚才提到那种美国梦衰落的感觉，这个梦是建立在经济富裕不断扩张的基础之上的。事实上，有一句来自美国石油高管的精彩引言，你会喜欢的。他说，这就像罗马人撤出哈德良长城时美国力量的退潮。我确实很喜欢那句话。
But I also, I like this comment from John Ehrlichman, who is what, he's a kind of Nixon aid. Yeah, he's one of Nixon's Berlin wall. Yeah. He says, conservation is not the Republican ethic. Well, he wasn't wrong. But you're right about environmentalism. So 72, 73, to me, is a kind of hinge moment for environmentalism
但我也喜欢约翰·埃利希曼的这条评论，他是谁，他是尼克松的一名助手。是的，他是尼克松的“柏林墙”团队成员之一。是的。他说，保护自然资源不是共和党人的伦理。嗯，他没有说错。但你关于环保主义的看法是对的。所以72、73年，对我来说是环保主义的一个转折点
because it's an earlier in 73, actually before the oil shock, that E.F. Shoemaker published his book, Small is Beautiful, which became a real Bible for the kind of 70s ecological movements. And you have all this talk of kind of the limits to growth, the costs of industrialisation. Well, we've got a question from Diego Mogado. Ah, friend of the show. Marxist friend of the show. Did the oil crisis highlighting the dependence on fossil fuels help the Greens in ecological movements to rise politically?
因为在73年初，实际上是在石油危机之前，E.F.舒马赫出版了他的书《小的是美好的》，这本书成为了70年代生态运动真正的圣经。你听到了所有关于增长的极限、工业化代价的讨论。嗯，我们有一个来自迭戈·莫加多的问题。啊，节目的老朋友。节目的马克思主义好朋友。石油危机凸显了对化石燃料的依赖，这是否有助于绿党和生态运动在政治上崛起？
Yes, undoubtedly. I mean, yes, in the broader sense. Although there is a kind of further complication, isn't there, which again has a massive echo into the present, that in Germany, which historically has a look to Russia rather than to the Middle East for its gas in particular, there's an environmental movement that targets nuclear power. So the French particularly, obviously,
是的，毫无疑问。我的意思是，是的，从更广泛的意义上讲。尽管还有一种进一步的复杂情况，不是吗？这在今天同样得到了强烈的呼应：在历史上倾向于从俄罗斯而不是中东进口天然气的德国（特别是其天然气供应），有一个环保运动将矛头指向了核电。所以法国人尤其是，显然，
have massively invested in nuclear power. The Germans don't. And am I right that that is a particular focus of kind of Soviet agitation? Yes, it is. A desire to ensure that Germany doesn't invest in nuclear power so that Germany will be dependent on Soviet gas flows. And that's something that kind of runs into the present day. that Germany will be dependent on Soviet gas flows. Well, again, yeah.
在核电方面进行了巨额投资。德国人则不然。我没记错的话，这正是苏联煽动的一个特定焦点吧？是的，确实如此。其目的是确保德国不投资核电，以便德国能够依赖苏联的天然气供应。而这一点一直延续到了今天。以便德国将依赖苏联的天然气供应。嗯，同样，是的。
And that's something that kind of runs into the present day. We talked about this in our Angela Merkel podcast, didn't we? About that German-Russian rapprochement about the availability of cheap gas is another of those themes of late 20th, 30th, 21st century politics that maybe we don't talk about very much, but our successors might say is terribly important in the long run so that's part of it actually even a very minor example of this ecologically in the netherlands obviously initially very badly hit um by the oil embargo that actually copes it right in the long run um in the netherlands they had car free sundays they
而这正是那种延续至今的东西。我们在安格拉·默克尔的那期播客里讨论过这个，不是吗？关于德俄之间就廉价天然气供应问题达成和解，这是20世纪晚期、30年代（注：此处口误，指20世纪末至21世纪）、21世纪政治的另一个主题，也许我们平时讨论得不多，但我们的后继者可能会认为从长远来看这极其重要，所以这也是其中的一部分，实际上，荷兰在生态环保方面就是一个非常微小的例子，当然最初受石油禁运的打击非常惨重，嗯，从长远来看它确实挺过来了，嗯，在荷兰，他们有无车星期日，他们
had car free sundays in other countries as well but in the netherlands it really takes off and obviously and you know it's a sort of urban myth. I don't know how true it is, but bicycles, the emphasis on public transport and bikes that you see in Denmark and in the Netherlands, that some of that derives from the impact of the oil crisis. I don't know how true that is. It sounds like a little bit too convenient,
在其他国家也有无车星期日，但在荷兰却真正盛行起来，显然，你知道，这有点像都市传说。我不知道这有多真实，但你在丹麦和荷兰看到的自行车、对公共交通和自行车的重视，其中一些确实源于石油危机的影响。我不知道这有多真实。听起来好像有点太巧合了，
but it's nice if it was. Silver linings and clouds um i think uh we should take a break at this point um yes so that we can advertise consumer durables require oil and gas to be brought to you um and when we come back let's zoom in on um on europe and perhaps specifically britain to find out how the European countries coped. Very good. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, we know that you particularly enjoy our promotional efforts and we have another one for you now,'t we tom a special offer for rest is history
不过如果真是这样那就太好了。祸福相依，嗯，我想，嗯，我们这时候应该休息一下，嗯，是的，这样我们就可以宣传一下耐用消费品，它们需要石油和气才能送到你手上；等我们回来，让我们把镜头聚焦于，嗯，欧洲，或许特别是英国，去看看欧洲各国是如何应对的。很好。如果你想收听无广告版、独家番外节目以及提前购买现场票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。现在，我们知道你们特别喜欢我们的促销活动，现在我们又有一个要推荐给你们了，汤姆，对吧，这是给《历史其余部分》听众的特别优惠。
listeners i think this may well be the third or fourth time we've mentioned this but uh we feel so strongly about it that we don't care we don't care and the offer is for um a magazine called unheard it's online um online magazine that aims to push back does it not dominic against herd mentality and promote independent thinkers. And among the independent thinkers that it has promoted are me. Top thinkers. Absolutely top thinkers. And you.
我想这可能已经是我们第三次或第四次提到这个了，但是，嗯，我们对它深信不疑，所以我们不在乎，我们根本不在乎。这个优惠是针对，嗯，一本叫做UnHerd的杂志，它是一个在线杂志，嗯，是一个旨在抵制——不是吗，多米尼克——抵制这种盲从心理并推广独立思想家的在线杂志。而它所推广的独立思想家当中就包括我。顶级思想家。绝对是顶级思想家。还有你。
Yeah. And today's episode, we're looking at the 1970s. And you have recently, you've written about that, haven't you? Space Hopper, Don Revy, manager of England, inflation at 27%, Harold Wilson as prime minister. So it's basically the sequel. If you listen to this podcast and you want to find out what happens next, you have to go to UnHerd and read this article.
对。而今天的节目，我们关注的是20世纪70年代。你最近也写过这个，不是吗？太空跳跳球、唐·里维（英格兰队主教练）、27%的通货膨胀率、作为首相的哈罗德·威尔逊。所以这基本上就是续集。如果你听了这期播客，想知道接下来发生了什么，你必须去UnHerd阅读这篇文章。
Are there any other articles, Tom? There is. Yes. And although they've prompted me to recommend this, it's an absolutely brilliant link because we've actually mentioned Suez and we've mentioned Britain's engagement in the Middle East, America's engagement, oil, all that kind of stuff. And there was a really fantastic piece by James Barr, who's a wonderful historian written about Anglo-French American involvement in the Middle East in the first half of the 20th century. And he's written one about the Suez crisis, arguing that it wasn't the self-inflicted error brought on by nostalgia that people think, but a rational response to financial pressure.
还有其他文章吗，汤姆？有的，是的。尽管他们促使我推荐这个，但这是一个绝对精彩的链接，因为我们刚才提到了苏伊士运河，提到了英国对中东的介入、美国的介入、石油以及所有这些类似的东西。詹姆斯·巴尔（James Barr）写了一篇非常棒的文章，他是一位杰出的历史学家，写过关于20世纪上半叶英法美在中东参与的文章。他写了一篇关于苏伊士运河危机的文章，认为这并不是人们所认为的由于怀旧而导致的自残式错误，而是对财务压力的一种理性回应。
I genuinely read that article and thought it was very good. Very good. Of course, genuinely. I'm not lying when I say that I'm interested in these articles. They're fabulous. I agree. It was a really, really fascinating piece. And sticking up for British policy in Suez is exactly the kind of pushback against herd mentality that unheard UNHCRD goes in for. And if you want to find out for yourself, there is a special offer. It's three months free and massive saving because normally it's one pound a week. So you've saved lots of pounds. You go to unheard.com slash rest. And just a further last reminder, that is U-N-H-E-R-D. Dot com slash rest. Yes.
我真的读了那篇文章，觉得非常好。非常好，当然是真的。我说我对这些文章感兴趣并不是在撒谎。它们太棒了。我同意。这确实是一篇非常非常精彩的文章。支持英国在苏伊士运河的政策，恰恰是UnHerd所热衷的那种对盲从心理的反击。如果你想亲自一探究竟，这里有一个特惠。可以免费三个月，而且能省下一大笔钱，因为通常是一英镑一周。所以你省下了很多英镑。你可以访问 unheard.com/rest。最后再提醒一次，那是 U-N-H-E-R-D 点 com 斜杠 rest。是的。
Thank you, Dominic. And now back to 1973. As Prime Minister, I want to speak to you simply and plainly about the grave emergency now facing the country. Jobs will be in danger and take home pay will be less. We shall have to postpone some of the hopes and aims we have set ourselves for expansion and for our standard of living. We shall have a harder Christmas than we have known since the war. Edward Heath.
谢谢你，多米尼克。现在让我们回到1973年。作为首相，我想简单明了地跟你们谈谈国家目前面临的严重紧急情况。工作岗位将受到威胁，实发工资将会减少。我们不得不推迟为实现扩张和提高生活水平而给自己设定的一些希望和目标。我们将度过自战争以来最艰难的一个圣诞节。爱德华·希思。
Who else, Dominic? I thought it was Mike Yarwood, actually. That was my impression of Edward Heath. Tom, you're on fire with your impersonations today. You are on fire. Yes. Why didn't you do... There are two great actors named Tom Holland in this world.
还有谁，多米尼克？我其实以为那是迈克·亚伍德（Mike Yarwood）。我当时对爱德华·希思的印象就是那样。汤姆，你今天的模仿秀简直火力全开。你太火了。是的。你为什么不……这个世界上有两个叫汤姆·霍兰的伟大演员。
Why? And I'm one of them. When we had Ian Kershaw on, why didn't you do your impersonation then of the subject of that podcast? Because I would get myself banned from the Cambridge Union, wouldn't I? You would. You can't do that. Well, Prince Harry got away with it.
为什么？而我是其中之一。当我们邀请伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）做客时，你当时为什么不模仿一下那期播客的主角呢？因为那样我会把自己被剑桥工会除名，对吧？你确实会被除名。你不能那样做。好吧，哈里王子都全身而退了。
Anyway. Okay. So that was on the 13th of December, 1973. And if Prime Minister, Conservative Prime Minister saying warning that we're going to have a terrible Christmas sounds familiar. That's one of the reasons that we're doing this because there are certain kind of echoes. Dominic, so you've written a fabulous book about the Heath government, state of emergency, the way we were Britain 1970 to 1974. If I read from the end of that, will you laugh at that like you did Alexander the Great? Well, I mean, if it's got inspirational messages for young boys and girls out there, no.
无论如何。好吧。那是1973年12月13日。如果一位首相，一位保守党首相发表警告说我们将有一个糟糕的圣诞节，听起来很耳熟。这就是我们做这个的原因之一，因为其中存在着某种呼应。多米尼克，你写过一本关于希思政府的精彩著作——《紧急状态：1970年至1974年的英国现状》。如果我朗读那本书的结尾，你会像嘲笑亚历山大大帝那样嘲笑它吗？好吧，我的意思是，如果里面有什么针对广大年轻男孩女孩的励志鸡汤，那不会。
So Britain basically goes into a kind of completely catastrophic meltdown as a result of this. Yes, more than anybody else. More than anyone else. We really shouldn't have done, really, because we weren't as hit as badly as, say, the United States or the Netherlands. No. But we have a shocker.
所以英国基本上因为这件事陷入了一种完全灾难性的崩溃。是的，比任何其他国家都严重。比任何人都要严重。其实我们真不该这样的，因为我们受到的打击并没有美国或荷兰那么严重。没有。但我们遭遇了一次巨大的震惊。
Well, Britain basically has a nervous breakdown as a result of the – because what the oil crisis does is it shines a very unsparing light on everything that's wrong with Britain's economic and political system. it's a bit like covid yeah i suppose so i mean the oil crisis and covid both kind of highlight the ways in which countries are not perhaps functioning as best they can yeah and ted heath has been prime minister since 1970 he's had this horrifically conflict sort of um contested confrontational three years um uh you know he's had one minor strike already he's had endless confrontations with the trade unions northern ireland has kind of descended into the abyss uh everything seems to have gone wrong for him and in the summer of 1973 he thinks that he's
嗯，英国基本上因此经历了一场精神崩溃——因为这场石油危机无情地将英国经济和政治体制中所有错误的东西都暴露在聚光灯下。这有点像新冠疫情。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，石油危机和新冠疫情都以某种方式突显了各国运转可能不够顺畅的问题。是的，爱德华·希思从1970年起就担任首相，他经历了这三年可怕的、冲突不断、对抗不断的艰难时期……嗯，你知道的，他已经经历了一场小规模的罢工，与工会的对抗没完没了，北爱尔兰也陷入了深渊……所有事情对好像他来说都出了问题。但在1973年夏天，他认为自己
possibly going to turn it around. He's got these incredibly grandiose anti-inflation policies that involve price and wage controls. And then basically the oil crisis hits and everything falls apart. And what makes it so resonant is that Britain had been, as you were saying, the chief, the great imperial power in the Middle East.
可能要扭转乾坤了。他推出了这些极其宏大的反通货膨胀政策，其中包括价格和工资管制。然后，石油危机基本上爆发了，一切都瓦解了。这件事之所以如此具有共鸣，是因为正如你所说，英国曾经是中东头号、伟大的帝国力量。
Yes, and had ruled Saudi Arabia, Kuwait, Iraq, Iran. Well, it had been the dominant power. The dominant power, yeah. And you give the example of... So these countries are all transformed too, by the way. The other country I think that's really transformed by the oil crisis actually is Iran, because it's in iran they make tons of money and the economy goes into overdrive inflation shoots through the roof and it's one of the big drivers actually the iranian revolution
是的，曾经统治过沙特阿拉伯、科威特、伊拉克、伊朗。嗯，它曾经是主导力量。主导力量，是的。你举了一个例子……所以这些国家也都发生了巨变，顺便说一句。另一个我认为被石油危机真正改变的国家实际上是伊朗，因为正是在伊朗，他们赚了大量的钱，经济进入了超速运转状态，通货膨胀飙升，这实际上也是伊朗伊斯兰革命的巨大推动力之一。
the kind of rapid breakneck uncontrolled economic growth and urbanization and so on but anyway we can save that for a future podcast well i did i did like the the um the shah of iran um in the 1973 oil crisis lecturing the west um saying that uh you know um that they've all just been kind of scamming money off you know the the riches of the middle east and saying your young boys and young girls who receive so much money from their fathers will have to think that they must earn their living somehow shocking of all people so So the Shah of Iran apparently pocketed, is supposed to have pocketed $10 billion in oil revenues personally during the 1970s.
那种急剧的、断崖式的、失控的经济增长和城市化等等，不过，我们可以把这些留到以后的播客里聊。嗯，我确实挺喜欢伊朗国王……在1973年石油危机中对西方说教，说什么，你知道的，他们所有人不过是一直在从（你知道的）中东的财富中敲诈金钱，还说你们那些从父亲那里拿到那么多钱的年轻男孩和女孩，必须考虑到你们必须靠自己的双手赚取生计。所有人中最令人震惊的居然是他。所以据称伊朗国王在20世纪70年代个人私吞了100亿美元的石油收入。
So he's not really terribly well placed to lecture others, I think, on living within their means. Anyway, back to Britain. So the real problem for Heath is he's lost one battle with the miners already and the miners basically have a knife to his throat they want a they want a 35 pay increase and they're asked for that even before the oil crisis starts i mean 35 sounds quite big so the well i'm going to um this isn't a position i'm i in, but I will defend the miners a little bit. No, I'm not saying it's wrong.
所以他实在没什么资格去教导别人如何量入为出，我认为。不管怎样，回到英国。所以希思面临的真正问题是，他已经输掉了与矿工的第一场较量，而矿工们基本上把刀架在了他的脖子上。他们要求加薪35%，而且在石油危机爆发之前他们就提出这个要求了。我的意思是，35%听起来相当高。所以……嗯，我打算……这不是我所处的立场，但我还是要为矿工们稍微辩护一下。不，我不是说这是错的。
Their pay had fallen behind in the 1960s behind other workers. Inflation is quite high. So their leaders say, well, we are asking for a fairer wage to keep up with steel workers and car workers and so on. 35% is a very high opening gambit. And Heath's pay policy envisaged 7%. The Coal Board offered them 16.5% and the miners still said no
在20世纪60年代，他们的工资水平已经落后于其他工人。通货膨胀率相当高。所以他们的领袖说，好吧，我们要争取更公平的工资，以便跟上钢铁工人、汽车工人等等的步伐。35%是一个非常高的开局要价。而希思的薪酬政策设想的增幅是7%。煤炭局向他们提供了16.5%的涨幅，但矿工们仍然拒绝了，
because they think they can get a better deal. Well, and they do get a better deal. Is this in 1970? No, this is in 1973. In 1972 they've already won one round. This is coming back for more. Now you could argue that in the long run, this does them terrible damage
因为他们认为自己能谈到更好的协议。嗯，他们确实谈到了更好的协议。这是在1970年吗？不，这是在1973年。在1972年他们已经赢得了一轮。这是卷土重来。现在你可以争辩说，从长远来看，这给他们带来了可怕的损害，
because it destroys their public popularity, that they keep coming back for big pay deals. But at the time, they think, well, we have a loaded gun and we propose to use it. They go into these meetings with Heath. And it's incredibly dangerous. Well, one miner says to, yeah, it's incredibly dangerous, horrible job.
因为它摧毁了他们的公众支持率，因为他们不断索要高额薪酬协议。但在当时，他们认为，好吧，我们手里有上膛的枪，我们打算使用它。他们与希思展开了这些会议。这极其危险。嗯，有一个矿工对……是的，极其危险，而且是一份糟糕的工作。
They've still got a lot of sentimentality among the public, a lot of sentimental support. And one miner says to Heathath at one point why can't you pay us for coal what you pay the arabs for oil and he has this big thing where he looks around he says you know you called for us in the first world war when we were there we dug out your coal for you and fought in the trenches i didn't see any arabs he says the same thing happened in the second world war now why won't you give us a deal? And Heath finds that question unanswerable. He's not going to give them,
他们在公众当中仍然享有很大程度的同情，很多同情性的支持。有一次，一个矿工对希思说，为什么你们不能按你们付给阿拉伯人石油的价钱付给我们煤炭钱呢？然后他滔滔不绝地说了一大堆，环顾四周说道，你知道，第一次世界大战时你们需要我们，我们在那里，我们为你们挖煤并在战壕里战斗，我当时可没看见什么阿拉伯人。他说同样的事情在第二次世界大战时也发生了。现在，为什么你们不给我们一个合理的待遇呢？希思觉得这个问题无法回答。他可不打算给他们……
he knows they don't want to hear a big lecture about geopolitical energy policy. So basically, the cabinet meets on the 12th of December and they agree on a three-day week. So shops, offices offices and so on are going to only have power for three days tv will have to go off at 10 30 floodlit sport obviously for an elite sportsman like yourself this would be devastating floodlit sport is and this is when heath so it's after that meeting that heath made that broadcast that you so spectacularly reproduced
他知道他们不想听什么关于地缘政治能源政策的长篇大论。所以基本上，内阁在12月12日开会，一致同意实施三天工作制。因此，商店、办公室等等将只能供电三天，电视必须在10点30分关闭，还有灯光体育赛事——显然，对于像你这样的精英运动员来说，这绝对是毁灭性的打击——灯光体育赛事是……正是在那次会议之后，希思发表了你模仿得如此出彩的那个广播讲话。
yeah and you have this absolute sense reproduced. Yeah, eerie. And you have this absolute sense in Britain it was eerie. Well, it's the Wiltshire thing, isn't it? Salisbury. That's the connection that probably explains why. So you have this strange thing in Britain, because I always think Christmas 1973 is the kind of peak of apocalyptic pessimism in Britain. So people are talking about tanks in the streets, about coups, about a national government,
对，你有一种绝对的感觉……重现。对，毛骨悚然。在英国，你有一种绝对的感觉，那就是毛骨悚然。嗯，那是威尔特郡的事，对吧？索尔兹伯里。这大概能解释原因的联系所在。所以在英国有这么一件奇怪的事，因为我一直认为1973年的圣诞节是英国末日悲观情绪的顶峰。人们谈论街上的坦克、政变、联合政府，
all this sort of stuff. And yet it's also, to my mind, the canonical Christmas. Because of Slade. Because of Slade. Because Slade are number one with Merry Christmas, everybody. And if you look at the TV schedules, it really is the canonical lineup. Morecambe and Wise, the two Ronnies,
所有诸如此类的事情。然而，在我看来，这也是最经典的圣诞节。因为斯雷德乐队（Slade）。因为斯雷德乐队。因为斯雷德乐队凭《圣诞快乐，每个人》（Merry Christmas Everybody）登上了排行榜首位。如果你看看电视节目单，它确实是最经典的阵容。莫康姆和怀斯（Morecambe and Wise）、两罗尼斯（The Two Ronnies）、
the Generation Game, the two Ronnies, the Generation game, and Mike Yarwood, a.k.a. Tom Holland, doing his impersonations. Yeah. So for British, I mean, obviously at this point... So for Christmas,
《世代游戏》（The Generation Game）、两罗尼斯、《世代游戏》，还有迈克·亚伍德（Mike Yarwood，也就是汤姆·霍兰）表演他的模仿秀。是的。所以对于英国人来说，显然在这个时候……所以到了圣诞节，
it doesn't get cut off at 10.30 then, does it? No, that's a good question. I don't know what happened at Christmas. Presumably it didn't get cut off at 10.30. I'd have to check the schedules. Yeah, you've caught me out there. Oh, well, excellent.
节目不会在10点30分被切断，对吧？不，这是一个好问题。我不知道圣诞节那天发生了什么。大概没有在10点30分被切断吧。我得去查查节目单。是的，你把我问住了。哦，好吧，太棒了。
That's fair enough. That makes up for Diogenes and the jar. For the pithos. Yes. I'll just have to go on and on and on about it. But you mentioned about anxieties about coups. Yeah. And, of course, a very, very significant star
这很公平。这足以弥补第欧根尼和酒坛了。为了那个瓦罐（pithos）。是的。我只能一直喋喋不休地讲下去了。但你刚才提到对政变的焦虑。是的。而且，当然，1973年《流行音乐顶峰》（Top of the Pops）上一位非常非常重要的明星对此非常激动。他坚坚持认为需要有一个极右翼阵线出现，横扫一切，把一切都清理干净。大卫·鲍伊。
at Top of the Pops in 1973 is very heated about this. He insists that there's a need for an extreme right front to come up and sweep everything off its feet and tidy everything up. David Bowie.
大卫·鲍伊。
David Bowie. David Bowie. Top, top, top fascist. Top fascist sympathiserist of the mid 1970s which you wouldn't necessarily expect and then he's seen doing fascist salutes at Victoria although he claims that he was waving he claims that he was waving to his fans
大卫·鲍伊。顶级、顶级、顶级法西斯。20世纪70年代中期顶级的法西斯同情者，这是你未必能料到的，然后人们看到他在维多利亚车站行纳粹礼，尽管他声称自己只是在挥手，他声称自己是在向粉丝挥手，
but I've seen I think I've seen an image of it, it does look very like a Nazi salute, yes so he was sort of flirting with these extreme personas in the mid 1970s I don't really want to beat up on David Bowie since he's not here to defend himself. But yeah, there is this sort of weird Weimar vibe in the... Alec Guinness, Alec Guinness as well, gives an interview to Time magazine in which he says,
但我看过，我想我见过那张照片，看起来真的很像纳粹礼，是的。所以在20世纪70年代中期，他确实在某种程度上与这些极端的公众形象调情。我其实不想痛打落水狗去抨击大卫·鲍伊，既然他已经不在了，无法为自己辩护。但，是的，当时有一种奇怪的魏玛氛围……亚利克·基尼斯（Alec Guinness），亚利克·基尼斯也接受了《时代》杂志的采访，在采访中他说，
you know, maybe Britain, a lot of people are saying Britain needs a strongman. And this sort of panic about... Yeah, well, a Jedi. This sort of panic about democracy and about can democracy... Is Britain... And the reason, you know, not just because we're a British podcast with lots of British listeners, but the reason it's important to talk about Britain
你知道，也许英国……很多人都在说英国需要一个强人。这种对……的恐慌。是的，嗯，一个绝地武士。这种对民主的恐慌，以及民主能否……英国是否……而且原因（不仅仅因为我们是一个拥有很多英国听众的英国播客），我们之所以有必要讨论英国，
is Britain is seen as Exhibit A. Every country in the world, the press says, Britain is what happens when you get it wrong. You know, Britain is a country that has signally failed to cope with the... Is there also a sense, though, that Britain was first into the Industrial Revolution and is first out of it? Absolutely. That perhaps it's kind of like the life cycle of a butterfly,
是因为英国被视为典型案例。世界上每个国家的媒体都说，英国就是当你把事情搞砸时会发生的情况。你知道，英国是一个明显未能应对……不过，是否也有一种感觉，那就是英国率先迎来了工业革命，也率先走出了工业革命？绝对有。也许这有点像一只蝴蝶的生命周期，
an industrial nation, that where Britain leads, other countries are going to follow. Absolutely there is. But there's also a sense of it being kind of the boot on the other foot and the former colonial underdogs kicking the master. So the classic one of that is... Big Idi. Idi Amin, the leader of Uganda.
一个工业化国家，英国引领的地方，其他国家也会效仿？绝对是这样的。但同时也有这样一种感觉，风水轮流转，曾经的殖民地底层正在痛踢主人。典型的例子就是……大伊迪。伊迪·阿明（Idi Amin），乌干达的领导人。
Yes. So he'd been in the Scottish Rifles or something, and they used to hit him on the head with a hammer to get him pumped up before rugby matches. So he's now the leader of Uganda. We talked about him with Tom Owolade, didn't we, in post-colonial Africa. So he offers some of his own savings
是的。他以前在苏格兰步枪团还是什么部队待过，他们以前在橄榄球比赛前用锤子敲他的头来让他兴奋起来。所以他现在成了乌干达的领导人。我们在后殖民时期的非洲讨论过他，跟汤姆·奥沃拉德（Tom Owolade）一起，对吧？所以他用他自己的一些积蓄
to help the British. He sends Heath all these telegrams that Heath keeps ignoring. Understandably. He starts the Save Britain Fund. And at one point, there's a fantastic moment where he sends a message to the Foreign Office, and he says, listen, I've got this lorry load of wheat and vegetables,
来帮助英国人。他给希思发了所有这些电报，而希思一直置之不理。这是可以理解的。他发起了“拯救英国基金”。在某个时刻，有一个绝妙的时刻，他给外交部发了一条消息，他说，听着，我有一卡车的小麦和蔬菜，
and they're rotting. Do you want them or not? Well, the Ugandan people have kindly donated them to help their British friends. And it is kind of, I mean, Idi Amin is quite a sort of monstrous man, but it is very comical that he's that he's sort of humiliating Britain
它们都快烂了。你们要不要？嗯，乌干达人民慷慨捐赠这些是为了帮助他们的英国朋友。这确实有点……我的意思是，伊迪·阿明是个相当畸形的恶魔，但他以这种方式羞辱英国，确实非常滑稽。
in this way and meanwhile January 1974 has come around and Britain has gone on to the three day week and it's not just Idi Amin
与此同时，1974年1月降临了，英国进入了三天工作制，不仅仅是伊迪·阿明，
it's also Der Spiegel isn't it yeah the swinging London of the 60s has given way to a London as gloomy as the city
还有《明镜周刊》，不是吗？是的，60年代摇摆的伦敦已经让位给了一个像查尔斯·狄更斯笔下那样阴暗的城市，曾经充满帝国气派的首都街道灯光稀疏，宛如英国前帝国城镇中贫民窟般的街道。
described by Charles Dickens with the once imperial streets of the capital sparsely lighted like the slummy streets of a former British imperial township oh yeah it's damning isn't it it's damning stuff um so do you but uh actually the three-day week's not that bad and a lot of so so that that was the pivot that's the classic Sandbrook pivot yeah so there's all kinds of you know humiliations disasters apocalypse and then you'll turn around and you'll talk about skateboards and space hoppers actually everybody loved and i thought that that reading your uh account of the three-day week in your excellent book state of emergency um there are quite a lot of echo
哦，是的，真是太遭了，不是吗？太糟糕了，嗯。所以你……但事实上，三天工作制也没那么糟，而且很多……所以这就是那个转折，经典的桑德布鲁克式转折。对，所以各种羞辱、灾难、世界末日，然后你话锋一转，开始谈论滑板和太空跳跳球。事实上每个人都很喜欢它，我发现阅读你在你那本优秀的著作《紧急状态》中对三天工作制的描述时，有很多呼应，
again echoes of of the current of which the the kind of panic buying of toilet paper is is one yeah which i gather also happened in japan i think that well the japanese of course are very the hygiene looms very large in japanese culture so yes once in a long time but there was panic buying of toilet paper um there was panic buying of petrol obviously right the way through but there was also people saying and here's the perhaps the lockdown echo that they quite enjoyed it yeah and the newspapers offering very wise advice about how to um use the time that you're not at work to spice up your sex life well the daily mail runs this column uh jane what's her name jane gaskell
再次呼应了当前的状况，其中抢购卫生纸就是其中之一。是的，据我所知这在日本也发生过，我想……日本人当然非常重视卫生问题，卫生在他们的文化中占据很大比重，所以是的，偶尔会这样，但当时确实出现了抢购卫生纸的现象，汽油当然也在一路遭到恐慌性抢购，但当时也有人说——这或许就是居家隔离（lockdown）的呼应——他们其实挺享受的。报纸还提出了非常明智的建议，教大家如何利用不用上班的时间来给自己的性生活增添情趣。
she says um the kids are doing a five-day week at school, so why don't couples take the chance to be more spontaneous? And Dominic, going very, very meta. Yeah. I mean, is it not possible that if the three-day week had not happened and that advice not been given, we wouldn't be doing the podcast now because you wouldn't exist? You'd be doing it with somebody else. Who would you do it with?
每日邮报》登了这样一个专栏，简……叫什么名字来着？简·加斯凯尔（Jane Gaskell），
You've got to explain. You've got to explain. So that advice was published nine months before i was born so i used to um when i used to when i was promoting that book i'd go around and i would say i literally may owe my existence to the daily mail but people thought that the daily mail were paying me to say that i think so well and to and to opec yeah to shake your to Sheikh Yamani and to the columnist of the Daily Mail. What does that tell you? Well, I think I might call you OPEC from now on.
她说，孩子们在学校实行五天工作制，所以为什么情侣们不抓住这个机会变得更随性一点呢？而且，多米尼克，这变得非常非常超现实（meta）。是的。我的意思是，如果三天工作制没有发生，那个建议没有被提出，我们现在是不是就不会在这里做播客了，因为你根本就不会存在？你会和别人一起做。你会和谁一起做？
Right. Okay, fair enough. So, yes. So, actually, yes, people are clearly not having too terrible a time. And Heath, Ted Heath. And isn't also, sorry, Dom on the on the parallels with the lockdown again also isn't it a fact that actually it's not as as bad economically as people had had expected so some people see this as evidence of britain's just utter shambolic laziness because they say
你得解释一下。你必须解释清楚。所以这个建议是在我出生前九个月发表的……所以我过去常常……当我宣传那本书的时候，我会到处说，我从字面意义上讲可能要归功于《每日邮报》让我存在于世。但人们以为《每日邮报》花钱让我这么说的，我想是的。好吧，还有欧佩克（OPEC），去向亚曼尼亲王（Sheikh Yamani）和《每日邮报》的专栏作家致敬。这说明了什么？好吧，我想我以后可能会叫你“欧佩克”了。
we don't lose we lost two days you might as well be three yeah well they say we don't lose. We lost two days. Might as well be three. Yeah, well, they say you lost two days. And firms are very ingenious about some, I mean, there are firms that use water wheels and things to kind of cope and candles. So they only lose, so their productivity is about 80%, despite the fact they've lost 40% of their working week. So people say, well, if you can somehow cope,
好。好吧，很有道理。所以，是的。所以，实际上，是的，人们的日子显然过得不算太糟。而希思，泰德·希思。而且，抱歉，多米尼克，关于再次与封锁进行平行对比，难道不是事实吗？事实上它在经济上并没有人们预期得那么糟糕，所以有些人认为这证明了英国人纯粹是一盘散沙般的懒惰，因为他们说
then that suggests you weren't working very hard to begin with. I mean, this is the sort of the foreign commentary about Britain, that we are very lazy and we're always having tea breaks and stuff. You see this all the time in the sort of discourse of the 1970s. So in a funny way, even our relative success at sort of escaping the worst consequences of the three day week turns into a stick to beat the British worker with. Yeah, OK, so stick to beat the British worker with with but i mean what what's the truth dominic are they um you know are they just coasting or are they actually reforming renovating um using the the pressures of of the uh of the three-day week to kind of generate new ways of running things a bit like has happened in the um in the covid yeah
我们没有损失……我们损失了两天，差不多就是三天吧。是的，好吧，他们说你损失了两天。差不多就是三天。是的，好吧，他们说你损失了两天。而且公司在应对方面非常机智，我的意思是，有些公司利用水车之类的东西来应付，还有蜡烛。所以他们只损失了……所以他们的生产力大约是80%，尽管他们损失了40%的工作周。所以人们说，如果你无论如何都能应付过去，
i think a bit of both actually tom i think if you listen to a lot of foreign observers said of Britain in the 60s and 70s that they were quite shocked by the working practices in British factories and offices. So the classic example of that actually is Star Wars when George Lucas comes and he just can't get into his head that the crew are having at Elstree or wherever it is, they're having all these tea breaks. But at the same time, firms are very ingenious. They work extra long hours. They find ways of coping with the three-day week. So anyway, so it's not as bad as people think. And that's bad news for Ted Heath, because he needed a kind of crisis atmosphere. And he needed the sense of apocalyptic doom because he want he's going to
那就说明你一开始工作得并不怎么卖力。我的意思是，这就是外界对英国的某种评论，认为我们非常懒惰，总是喝茶休息什么的。你在20世纪70年代的种种言论中随时都能看到这一点。所以有趣的是，我们在某种程度上成功逃避了三天工作制最糟糕后果的相对成功，反而变成了鞭笞英国工人的另一根棍棒。是的，好吧，成了鞭笞英国工人的棍棒，但我的意思是，真相到底是什么呢，多米尼克？他们……你知道的，他们只是在随波逐流，还是实际上在进行改革、整顿……利用三天工作制带来的压力来开创管理事物的新方式，有点像新冠疫情期间发生的那样？
fight a snap general election on the issue of who governs the government or the miners and the more comfortable people are the more relaxed they are the more they will not feel motivated to go out and vote for the government they'll feel sorry for the miners instead yeah and so actually his big gamble is a is a disaster for him i say the the answer to the question of who governs Britain is not you. Yes, exactly. And he loses the premiership, goes into a massive sulk. Yes. Retreats to Salisbury. And so things are set up for the 80s. But I suppose also, I mean, much more importantly, perhaps even than that, looking at the present, is that in Britain, as in America, as in the rest of Europe, that the legacy of this is to make people question their energy use. Yeah, I think that's right. You would say that in a very, very long term. But actually, the interesting thing is that in the short to medium term,
我认为两者兼而有之，汤姆。我想如果你听听许多外国观察家对60年代和70年代英国的评价，他们对英国工厂和办公室里的工作习惯感到相当震惊。所以这方面的经典例子实际上是《星球大战》，当乔治·卢卡斯来到埃尔斯特里或其他什么地方时，他简直无法理解剧组成员怎么会有那么多次茶歇。但与此同时，公司非常机智。他们加班加点。他们找到了应对三天工作制的方法。所以无论如何，事情并没有人们想象的那么糟。这对泰德·希思来说是个坏消息，因为他需要一种危机氛围。他需要那种末日降临的感觉，因为他想要……他打算
that's quite an unpopular sort of political vision. So the person who really comes to incarnate that is the person who... So Nixon comes and goes. He obviously resigns. Gerald Ford has a brief spell. And then in comes Jimmy Carter. So Jimmy Carter is Mr. Energy. And Jimmy Carter says, you know, we have to learn the lessons from this.
就“究竟是谁在统治国家——是政府还是矿工”这一议题发起一场突击大选。而人们越觉得舒适，越觉得放松，他们去投票支持政府的动力就越不足，反而会同情矿工。是的，所以实际上他的这场巨大赌博对他来说是一场灾难。可以说，对于“谁在统治英国”这个问题，答案不是你。是的， exatamente（葡萄牙语：正是如此）。他失去了首相职位，陷入了巨大的怄气中。是的。退隐到索尔兹伯里。所以一切都为80年代做好了铺垫。但我想，更重要的也许甚至比这还要重要的是，放眼当下，在英国、在美国、在欧洲其他地方，这一切的遗产就是让人们开始质疑自己的能源消耗。是的，我认为这很中肯。你会说这是一个非常非常长期的影响。但实际上，有趣的是，在短期到中期内，
We have to learn the lessons of our dependence on foreign oil. We have to conserve energy. We have to be more sensible. We have to be more respectful of the planet, all that kind of thing. And he is voted out in a landslide to Ronald Reagan in 1980. And then actually in the 80s, oil prices, there's a glut of oil on the market. So oil is incredibly cheap. And it's as though the lessons are kind of forgotten for a time. But I mean, oil still is kind of relatively cheap. I mean, right the way up to now, but that's not
那是一种相当不受欢迎的政治愿景。所以真正将其实践并化身其中的人是……所以尼克松来来去去。他显然辞职了。杰拉尔德·福特经历了短暂的任期。然后吉米·卡特上台了。所以吉米·卡特就是“能源先生”。吉米·卡特说，你知道，我们必须从中吸取教训。
kind of... The anxiety about the use of oil gets divorced from the cost, doesn't it? I mean, essentially what the oil crisis does of 73 is to get people worrying about its use and where it may lead. And the anxieties that are consequent on that outlast the price spike. Yes, they do. The attempt of the cartel to... I think it's absolutely right to say
我们必须吸取我们对外国石油依赖的教训。我们必须节约能源。我们必须更明智。我们必须更加尊重地球，诸如此类的事情。结果他在1980年的大选中被罗纳德·里根以压倒性优势投票赶下了台。然后实际上在80年代，石油价格大跌，市场上石油过剩。所以石油便宜得难以置信。就好像这些教训被暂时遗忘了一样。但我的意思是，石油在某种程度上仍然相对便宜。我的意思是，一直持续到现在，但这并非
that there's a general anxiety about fossil fuels and about dependent it's about the idea of dependence isn't it it's not it's the idea of dependence on two things the idea of dependence on foreign actors that you no longer control as in these this is the anxiety of kind of former colonial powers who are now dependent on their their former subjects um but it's also the anxiety of being dependent on a finite commodity. And so this is the point at which I think you start getting people writing books and making predictions to say, one day we will run out. We'll run out quite soon. And what will we do then? So the question from Nathan Hogg, has OPEC power declined since the 70s? I mean, you could say
某种……对使用石油的焦虑与成本脱钩了，不是吗？我的意思是，本质上73年的石油危机让人们开始担心它的使用以及它可能导致的后果。由此产生的焦虑比价格飙升持续的时间更长。是的，确实如此。卡特尔试图……我认为这样说绝对正确，
that perhaps one of the reasons why they didn't um use the embargo and and the old weapon as they might have done previously is that perhaps wiser heads among them realize that it might be a pyrrhic victory in the long run yeah i suppose it is a pyrrhic victory you're right because they can it's also a weapon you can only really use once i think yeah um it's sort of once you've used it then the people have wised up to it and they start from 1973 onwards people are making provision for what happens if
即人们对化石燃料以及对依赖性普遍存在焦虑——这实际上是关于依赖性的概念，不是吗？这不仅仅是对两个事物的依赖感：对不再由你控制的外国演员的依赖感，就像这些是前殖民大国现在依赖其前臣民的焦虑一样；
there's a war in the Middle East what happens if we have to there is the next great turbulence in the Middle East the Iranian revolution people are a little bit better prepared for it than they were back in 1973 and then again with the Gulf War in 1991 and so on but that habit of thinking about how do we wean ourselves off oil and off you know fossil fuels generally yeah whether it expresses itself through an interest in developing um nuclear energy
但这也是对依赖一种有限商品的焦虑。所以正是在这个时候，我认为你开始看到人们写书并做出预测，说总有一天我们会用完的。我们很快就会用完。那我们到时候该怎么办呢？来自内森·霍格（Nathan Hogg）的问题：自70年代以来，欧佩克的权力下降了吗？我的意思是，你可以说，
or wind energy or whatever that is a kind of habit that gets turbocharged in the 70s and it's one that it's a kind of a wave that we're still surfing now yeah absolutely the 2020s so for example shale gas the extraction of shale gas that that's given a huge boost in america so nixon yeah nixon so nixon has this idea for something called project independence he calls it he wants a united states that is entirely that is no longer dependent on imported energy at all. I mean, he never really gets it. I mean, it's a sort of pie-in-the-sky idea. But that sort of idea of ridding yourself from the crippling dependence,
也许他们没有像以前那样使用禁运和石油武器的原因之一，是他们当中更明智的人意识到从长远来看这可能是一场惨胜。是的，我想这确实是一场惨胜，你说得对，因为他们可以……这也是一种你基本上只能使用一次的武器，我想。嗯，这有点像一旦你使用了它，人们就会对此有所防范，从1973年开始，人们就开始为中东发生战争时该怎么办、如果我们必须应对中东下一次大动荡（伊朗伊斯兰革命）时该怎么办做好准备，人们比1973年时做好了更好的准备，然后是1991年的海湾战争等等。但那种思考“我们如何让自己摆脱对石油以及普遍对化石燃料的依赖”的习惯——
that's there for the next 30 years or so. And then I suppose the next element is, which you don't see at all in the commentary in the 1970 1970s is we're destroying the planet by burning all this oil because people don't really talk about that particularly in the 70s it's more the economic costs rather than the sort of environmental costs but now you've got both i mean you've got you've got we've got to wean ourselves off oil because we've got to save the planet and we've got to wean ourselves off oil because the middle east is an absolute nightmare. It's a kind of Magi-mix. And every time we put our hand in it, it just chews and spits bits of finger.
无论它是通过对发展核能的兴趣来表达，
Do people put their hands in Magi-mixes? I don't know. Maybe they do. I think if you're George Bush, they do. Yes. Or your friend Tony Blair. Well, whatever. He had his reason.
还是风能或其他什么，这都是一种在70年代得到涡轮增压般强化的习惯，而且这是我们至今仍在冲浪的浪潮。是的，绝对是20年代的浪潮。所以例如页岩气，页岩气的开采，这在美国得到了巨大的推动。所以尼克松……尼克松有一个名为“独立计划”的想法，他称之为他想要一个完全不再依赖进口能源的美国。我的意思是，他从未真正实现过。我的意思是，那是一种空中楼阁般的想法。但这种摆脱毁灭性依赖的想法，
But, Tom, there's another element to this, which you mentioned in your fantastic impersonation of the New york times which is this question of thrift so it's this idea of the kind of getting back to a kind of roman republican virtues and that's not worked has it the dependence on oil has is luxury basically because you saw this even in 1973 74 and some of the commentary people would say you know we should live simpler lives we've we've become dissipated. Yeah, it's the good life. Exactly. It's that kind of, and it's not just about saving the planet and it's not just about, you know, not getting into Middle Eastern politics.
在接下来的大约30年里一直存在。然后我想接下来的一个要素是——你在70年代的评论中根本看不到的——那就是我们在燃烧所有这些石油的同时正在摧毁地球，因为人们在70年代特别不怎么谈论这个，这更多是关于经济成本，而不是某种环境成本。但现在你两者兼具了——我的意思是，我们必须戒掉石油，因为我们要拯救地球；我们必须戒掉石油，因为中东简直是一场绝对的噩梦。它就像一个魔力搅拌机（Magi-mix）。每一次我们把手伸进去，它就会把手指嚼碎并吐出来。
It's also about being a better person through, you know, a plainer, simpler lifestyle. And I think the oil crisis absolutely turbocharges that. And there, again, you have a parallel with COVID and the lockdowns, because sometimes you would hear people saying, you know, I've been baking sourdough bread for the last six weeks. I'm so happy I don't have to go to work anymore.
人们真的会把手伸进魔力搅拌机里吗？我不知道。也许会的。我想如果你是乔治·W·布什，他们就会。是的。或者你的朋友托尼·布莱尔。不管怎样，他有他的理由。
I can listen to the birds. Yeah, exactly. No, I think it's a great topic. And I think it's fascinating both as a mirror, but also because obviously, you know, it's clear that this is an absolutely crucial pivot in 20th century global history.
但是，汤姆，这还有另一个要素，你在对《纽约时报》的精彩模仿中提到了这一点，那就是关于节俭的问题——所以这就是回归某种罗马共和美德的想法，而这并没有成功，对吧？对石油的依赖基本上就是一种奢侈，因为你在1973-1974年的一些评论中就能看到这一点，人们会说，你知道，我们应该过更简朴的生活，我们已经变得放纵了。
And in a sense where, you know, we're on, we're, we're on the one side of that. Yeah. So brilliant, Dominic.
是的，这就是美好生活。没错，就是那种……而且这不仅仅是为了拯救地球，也不仅仅是为了不卷入中东政治。
Thanks so much. That was fascinating stuff. Thank you, Tom. Thank you. And we've, we've never, ever had better impersonations on the show.
这也是为了通过更朴素、更简单的生活方式成为一个更好的人。我认为石油危机绝对极大地催化了这一点。在这里，你再次看到了与新冠疫情和封锁的相似之处，因为有时你会听到人们说，你知道，过去六周我一直在烤酸面包。我太高兴不用再去上班了。
I'm aware that I've been letting the side down up till now. I, my, my cowboy impersonation was, was a terrible one. I normally do a much better one than that um i just i don't know i didn't have enough self-confidence oddly um so what are we doing next that you can do more voices our next show is on australia it's on the early history of australia oh yeah what are you going to do I don't know oh my god is that Paul Hogan I can't Shane Warne
我可以听听鸟叫。是的，完全如此。不，我认为这是一个很棒的话题。而且我认为它无论是作为一面镜子，还是因为显然（你知道的）很清楚这是20世纪全球历史中一个绝对至关重要的转折点，都极其迷人。
Warney oh this is this is so exciting you're really spoiling us it's the Ferrero Rocher of accents yes
从某种意义上说，我们（你知道的）正处于……我们正处于那个转折的一侧。是的。所以太棒了，多米尼克。
so huge excitement brewing there so we'll see you back there we'll be going down under and that's my impression of a didgeridoo on that note We'll see you back there. We'll be going down under. That's my impression of a didgeridoo. On that note, I think it's time to end.
非常感谢。太精彩了。谢谢你，汤姆。谢谢。而且我们在节目中从来、从来没有过更好的模仿秀了。
Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我意识到我到现在为止一直在拖大家的后腿。我……我的牛仔模仿秀简直糟透了。我通常能做得比那好得多……嗯，我只是……我不知道，奇怪的是我当时不够自信……那么我们接下来要做什么，好让你能模仿更多声音？我们的下一期节目是关于澳大利亚的，讲的是澳大利亚的早期历史。哦，太棒了。你要模仿谁？我不知道。噢，天哪，那是保罗·霍根（Paul Hogan）吗？我模仿不了，那是肖恩·沃恩（Shane Warne）！